in this video i want to talk a little
bit about nucleophile strength
nucleophile
strength and just as a bit of review a
nucleophile is an atom or an ion or a
molecule that really wants to give away
electrons and it really wants to give
away electrons to i guess you could view
it as another nucleus and form a bond
with that nucleus and that's why it
loves nucleus file literally means lover
so it's a nucleus lover so it wants to
it wants to give
give electrons
a way
to bond with another nucleus to bond
with
a nucleus and what we want to think
about in this video is what makes
something a really strong nucleophile so
it really wants to do this versus a
medium nucleophile versus a weak
nucleophile so let's just start with the
strong
the strong nucleophile so i'll write it
right over here so let's think about
what a strong nucleophile would be like
well any nucleophile it will have to
have some kind of excess electrons
either it has a full negative charge and
you'll see in kind of the strong and the
medium nucleophiles that will be the
case or maybe it might have a partial
negative charge and that might be the
case for the weak nucleophiles so in
general it's going to have to have some
type of excess electrons and that's
usually the case with things that are
pretty electronegative so it has to have
be electronegative enough to have to
have gotten an electron to give away so
let me write this down here so in
general
a nucleophile so before we talk about
strong nucleophiles they have to be
electro
electronegative
enough
to have
excess
excess
negative
to have excess negative charge and if
you remember about electronegativity it
increases from the bottom left of the
periodic table
to
the top right and in general in organic
chemistry the the atoms or or i guess
the parts of molecules or i guess the
ion versions of atoms that are
electronegative enough to have excess
negative charge are going to be in this
area right around here they're going to
be in this area
right
over here so most of the nucleophiles
you're going to see are going to have
they're either going to be the the
negative ion version of some of these
atoms or they're going to have these
atoms attached to other things but the
the part that actually really wants to
give away the electron is going to
usually be dealing with one of these one
of these atoms right over here
so you say okay fine so these are you
know these are potential nucleophiles
but which of these are going to be
strong versus medium versus weak now
remember what we said a nucleophile it
really wants to give away the electrons
and we know that electronegativity that
means that you really want to hog
electrons so in order to just even be a
nucleophile you have to be
electronegative enough to have x to have
an excess negative charge so that's why
we're usually going to see these
characters but the strongest of the
nucleophiles is going to be the ones
that can be a nucleophile but aren't too
electronegative they still want to give
away electrons and if you look at out of
these right here which is the one that
is least electronegative well if you
were to compare let's compare let's
compare iodide to fluoride let me just
compare these two so if i were to
compare so fluoride so fluorine has 7
valence electrons right it's in group 7
1 2 3 4 5 6 7.
one two three four five six
seven and let's say it swipes to become
fluoride it would have to swipe an
electron from someplace else which is
not a crazy thing for fluorine to do
because it's so electronegative so if it
swipes it from someplace else then you
have a negative charge so this is the
fluoride anion let's compare that to the
iodide anion so iodide iodine will look
like this once again it's in the same
group it's a halogen it also has
seven electrons
when it's in its neutral state but it's
reasonably electronegative it is
electronegative enough to have excess
negative charge or to swipe it from
someone else so maybe it swipes it from
someone else just like fluorine did and
now we have the iodide the iodide anion
my question is which of these are going
to be
more which are these are going to be a
stronger
nucleophile
well the stronger nucleophile is the one
that wants to give away its electron
more and iodide or we should say iodine
is less electronegative than fluorine so
this iodide ion is more likely to give
away it's more likely to give away its
electron so this right here so iodide is
actually one of the strongest
nucleophiles
so one of the strongest so it's
electronegative enough to have a charge
to have swiped an electron from someone
else but once it has it it's not so
electronegative that it wants to keep it
it really wants to give it away so this
is a very strong nucleophile now if you
ask well what about a medium nucleophile
well medium nucleophiles would be
something like fluoride fluoride this
fluoride anion right there it's
electronegative it's swiped an electron
it has an extra electron to give away
right it has this extra electron to give
away but it's you know it's kind of
happy keeping it because it's so
electronegative it kind of likes keeping
it so that right there is a
medium
is a medium nucleophile and another one
just so that you see that they're not
always just single atom
single atoms or single ions another one
is hydroxide
oh so hydroxide in
oxygen typically only has six valence
electrons in a neutral state so it's one
two three four five six but when you get
hydroxide it swiped an electron from
some other atom and so then it becomes a
hydroxide anion
it's usually swiping it from an from a
hydrogen and so this will have a
negative charge it has an excess it has
an excess electron to give away but
oxygen is so electronegative that's kind
of like well you know i don't mind
keeping it iodide says hey i really want
to give it away hydroxide says well i
have it i could give it away but you
know i'm pretty electronegative so i
kind of like hogging it so this is also
another example this is another example
of a medium strength nucleophile so the
last one we have to think about is well
what's going to be a weak if this up
here if this up here when they have an
extra electron if this is medium and
these are the most electronegative this
down here if this is a strong
nucleophile what's going to be a weak
nucleophile
what is going to be a
weak
a weak nucleophile well weak
nucleophiles don't even have an excess a
full excess negative charge they might
just have a partial negative charge and
so they might be kind of predisposed
to maybe giving an electron if the maybe
the person they give the nucleus that
they want to that they're in love with
is you know really electron deficient
maybe it's a carbocation of some kind
and the most typical
weak
nucleophile is actually just water just
h2o h2o just looks like this you have
oxygen
bonded to two hydrogens and the oxygen
is neutral has one two three four
five six valence electrons and overall
it's neutral but we know that oxygen is
much more electronegative than the
hydrogens so it hogs the electrons it
even hogs hydrogen's electrons that are
here
and there and since they spend more time
around the oxygen the oxygen end has a
partial negative charge and the hydrogen
ends have partial
have partial positive charges and
because of this this this part right
here i mean we already said when even
when oxygen has a full negative charge
it's still only a medium electro a
medium nucleophile have to be very clear
it's still only a medium nucleophile so
when you can imagine when it has only a
partial negative charge as in the case
of water it's going to be a weak
nucleophile but it still might want to
give away its electron to something like
this if i have a carbocation some
sitting let's say i have something that
looks like this
a carbon that's essentially maybe it's
lost one of its it's it's lost you know
the thing that it was bonded to stole
its electron so now this carbon has a
positive charge it's a carbocation it's
a tertiary carbocation this in a normal
case this wouldn't be a strong
nucleophile but this guy could say well
you know this guy really needs an
electron i have some excess negative
charge maybe i can give my electron to
that guy and bond with it and we saw
that actually in the sn1 reaction and
the whole discussion over strong and
weak nucleophiles
the reason why it's even important to
begin with is it's going to help us
decide whether we're going to have
either an sn1 or an sn2 or what type of
reaction will go we'll we'll go ahead
based on what we have
floating around in our solution